[Music]
ghost makes guy drink want to drink
whiskey is this the guy whose wife left
him they want me to drink another
whiskey dude this is a sketch right this
is a
sketch this is a sketch
right this is so funny that was a weird
impulse Man Billy starts acting very
strange has this sudden impulse to drink
more
whiskey this is a you joke come on dude
you wrote this seriously you wrote this
yeah seriously to the fullest
man I have never had an Impulse I want
to drink that right now I want another
shot of this whiskey
right this is Cody after [__] to deep
yeah yeah exactly there's a ghost in
here bro he wants me to have this
Buffalo look at this dude bro bro bro I
can't stop dude this is [__] crazy I
can't stop I'm not doing this at
[Laughter]
all someone's making me drink four
lroy that's just some Edward 40 hand
[__] dud I can't bro this is
crazy bro I don't even know what this
symbol
means
yeah
bro I'm not doing any of this
I'm not bro bro the ghost put Molly in
my
pocket bro I've never done this before I
can't control
myself I don't dude I'm not even I'm not
even I'm not even looking which one do
you
[Laughter]
want that's so funny cutting it up all
casually I don't even do this [__] man
I've actually I've actually never done
this before yeah it's for you guys man
know what do you mean this is for you
guys yeah oh
[Laughter]
oh oh
[__] yo did you guys see that that [__]
was crazy bro I got here it comes again
oh my
God n I'm just [__] around
dude yeah just
oh no bro just taking your
drink oh God uhoh whoops it's a
g can I just do it oh you might get
drunk no they're telling me we should do
it do it cheers that would be your third
shot you've never done this before on a
lock down that's three that's three
shots of whiskey he just did bro feels
good
yeah talking about the ghost
there he's like yeah it's hidden yeah
yeah oh that [__] feels
a real ghost hunters dude that is
awesome oh that's on Discovery yeah [__]
that's the type of [__] they would have
had us doing bro seriously dude if it's
that I would do
that ghost hunting
liquor yeah I think that' be we heard
there's a really big ghost in here what
is that gravity bong yeah
whoa no dude the the ghost is telling me
to dip my cigarette in the
[Laughter]
cocaine no dude it's telling me these c
i I know the cigarettes are
wet yeah that'd be fun show yeah to do
every week every week is the same thing
yeah walk dude stop bringing whiskey to
the [__] ghost hunting thing we're
trying
to every just gets more and more whoa a
cabinet of of liquor in this Asylum who
put this
here it's all branded content yeah what
Jagger minded Jagger Jagermeister
branded
fridge whoa whoa a fridge full of
Fireball n cinnamon whiskey I hate this
I hate this stuff I haven't in years man
wait something's happening
do you guys want one no
whoa I was say this is some Edward 40and
[__] yeah it's like a dude with like
taped up yeah just taped up Old English
you know
40s oh man [__] ghost got
[Laughter]
me
yeah man you see that I don't know what
the [__] it was but like I saw 9,000 Tik
toks about sammon Colby's new
video they like do paranormal [__] oh
okay but it's all like I they they've
been doing it for like years and years
and years which makes me think okay this
is this [__] is all fake anyways right
yeah but I don't know apparently that
video the one that's 7.8 million views
people on Tik Tok are like you will not
believe like adults were like this is
actually the [__] craziest thing ever
can you click this and then just go to
the heat map like where is everyone like
replaying it oh those ah they know what
they did they know what they did wait
can you turn that off you can over
500,000 likes on this video what the
[__] how are people so into this [__] so
what what was the gist of this does
anyone know you're not up on you're not
up on Sam and Colby no the one with
Ethan Hawk is Sinister yeah Conjuring
with like Patrick Wilson but not
Insidious oh yeah yeah this [__] but
what's the actual story in a house
there's a ghost that wants you get get
[__]
up [__] up yeah let's do a ghost movie
with the ghost is just an
alcoholic what what you say let's do a
ghost movie with the ghost is an
alcoholic yeah yeah just a [__] heavy
set annoying guy yeah yeah just barging
in a 7 y'all watch the dealers game yeah
holy [__] what a blowout dude drunk
you're drunk already Jesus i' about like
4 it's [__] 11:00 a.m. this is
America just in the middle of the
night yeah
yeah just a [__] loud piss sound yeah
oh [__]
[__] to the top of the stairs yeah oh my
my
God yeah and then he just falls down the
stairs know it's
just the kids in the
room anyone seen the
totinos no this is the ghost all right
I'm going run out and get some totinos
I'm good don't ask yeah I'm fine then he
just possessed is their
car it's a tree yeah gets out comes back
I didn't get the
cinos well I think your car something
wrong with
it the malfunction I don't know you know
you guys are this you know man you
know's [__]
stupid autopilot doesn't work man it's a
scam